all right
[Music]
foreign
it could be that okay but what I what
I'm saying is that like uh
you should be able to read your
teacher's body
uh when he is like
do you get what I'm saying uh and the UK
should be able to do that too so that
you know
that wasn't what I was supposed to do
okay and then you fix it okay
so what what was happening and I was
watching your group there is they feel a
little projection so they feel a little
you see a little and then but they take
off now into them
and it's kind of just like I'm trying to
do a bench press you know with just in
terms of force and then my spotter comes
up and takes the bar off off me because
see that so it's kind of it's kind of
like that even though it's not muscular
okay it's a way of the UK bleeding off
the energy okay
so in order for me to get a decent wrap
let's say you you feel that you see and
then they start falling right away but
if you pay attention when I go here
there's no reason to fall do you see so
for example if I go here and then you
feel me take it back
but
people will feel that and then go right
into them
okay so if that's the case
and I stay where I am then there's no
more conditioning no more Pokemon
okay so I might I for here and you
starting to fall I would follow you
do you see that
um I wouldn't necessarily
ask the question from the arm point of
view
okay I would ask more what is your
vector
uh
as you're rebounding energy back into
them okay so for example we're here and
if my Vector is on your shoulders they
stay there please and I'm going over
this hata band you see that I it will
kind of knock you over but it's not the
drill
okay so there my arms are moving you see
it's going over I'm trying to get you
it's not literally
okay it's Gotta Be we it I gotta be in
your Center okay so I'm in your Center
I'm just keep aiming
Interceptor and again like it's better
you don't fall you see and like I don't
I I wouldn't smack on the ground unless
I absolutely could not hold the grit do
you understand that so like take that
last rep and you felt the fall and you
let go here to smack on the ground yes
we're not high enough so sometimes I'll
project and that's it
you see and I want you to go
go do you understand that and all you
got to do is trust
uh
trust Okay so
um once my UK has that trust then I can
keep working in the center you see
in the center
innocent
so pay attention to where you feel it
and I'll do it both ways Okay so
around your Center yes
around your Center in yourself
you see that this
over your Center
you get it so I I saw a lot of you going
around that part
okay
so
sometimes you go around it because it
feels too heavy
holy cow so you're trying to take some
weight off of it you see
um
and in that sense that comes back to the
arms you you are having your arms maybe
going in and out
to move him okay
and instead I would like to see your
Center Your Body Move
your body moves so let's say you feel
one oh I can't go anymore instead of
going around his his Center I would
rather you move your body
body
watch my torso for how much
should there actually is it might or or
pay attention to my head my head is not
staying still or my torso can't
foreign
arms stay body moves
and as you're watching for that then go
back and watch How I always try to move
this in this training in some throws I
might want to move his head I might want
to move just his elbow or something but
in this training it goes
uh Center ground Center Center ground
okay that's what I'm doing here
not going around that
hot off okay
all right let's try
it okay so
Let There are what just for simplicity's
sake we can call you call it yogic or
alchemic alchemical
okay uh understandings of the body which
means in particular that certain
emotional states thoughts
um ideas words too
um sounds even
things that seem immaterial manifest in
the body in a particular way okay
and here we have a a center let's for
simplicity's sake let's call it a a
center activation okay or a body
organization that utilizes a center
activation okay and let's contrast that
organization
with like a flesh response mentioned in
the podcast right so the Flint's
response I kind of go like that do you
see and if you look at me my pelvis like
that didn't look weird to you that
looked like a Flinch response by pelvis
abdominal region just totally disengaged
if you paint it it's all mushy here you
see
um which is the opposite if I take pull
my Coq posture and you see that that
difference can you see that okay
so the question is I I would put it this
way which ideas thoughts feelings Etc go
with the broken center it's going to be
a fear of the fear manifests in the
broken Center okay and from the UK side
of it it makes you
as a training partner uh not very
projectable
and
which might raise its own issues for in
giwasa but in kokudosa I just have a
barbell that isn't very structurally
sound okay so I can't really cultivate
the skill okay
um
let's try some things now so you're just
going to fall back on your own like a
back break while like some energies
coming in well
and you do it again
and do it with your best form for the
backbreakable
all right
and you feel your your Center you keep
going pay attention
is he pretty organized so for example uh
let's sit on your bottom and put your
feet out
separate them and we'll do that uh in
chemi drill where you lock your Center
and you go around okay
we go
now it should be where the broken Center
mushy Center would look like in that
drill yes keep going
yes
and let's organize it again
okay whoo all right
so uh when we doing the technique and
you can see it did you feel it okay
see it got disorganized and you look you
did the mushiness do you see that right
okay so let's try uh and so that makes
you not projectable but from your side
you are now not doing the training from
the inside okay so when you locked your
body with that Center organization and
if you pay attention not to you but to
me do you see my central organization is
doing the same thing
So You Train 50 and you've got mushy
again okay and you can see you hold your
breath which is another sign of the fear
right okay so we're gonna try
um we know you can do the break Fall by
yourself right okay
and now you're going to just offer your
hand okay
and I'm going to move out a technique
lab you see I'm just the energy and
you're you're going to keep your Center
organized
in that case you're in the rice ball
little to me part where you where you
came
like that
you see as you're going backwards this
part should be here okay
so
here
now do it without me
lock lock and then much better and then
with me lock until it comes off just a
little do it without me
okay
and then with me
and I want you want you now you're
you're pushing on me I'm not pushing you
okay you push on me and it takes me
little kind of
kind of lock lock this don't come don't
come forward
lock that and the whole body the whole
body goes by yes
okay feel that hand you push on me and
don't push on this hand
[Music]
when you do it by yourself
you know just fall by yourself
[Music]
but when you go when you for your chest
to come forward you have to break your
Center
okay you just go back on that butt
yes
you push on me and you do the same thing
you pushing on me
this is so you provide I don't know if
you can see it or feel it okay when you
do your fall your body goes back and
your leg comes out watch my body lock
just like how it's going to continue
around I'm not going like this
see that hinge
okay
but when you push it on me you go here I
like that
this goes here this goes into your
balance
let's try it again
yes
it's not that high
oh gooey
better breathe out
get your feet up
feet up flex your feet
better
again
a little tiny bit
don't crunch
go back and open
yep better flex your feet get awareness
all the way down your heels
much better that's it
better breathe out flex your feet
better okay let's try that truck go
okay so if we if we look deeper into
that uh there's telltale signs of it
okay
um
so he's gonna do it slow so I can talk
as you guys okay so one do you see
that's a Telltale song
so I he's he's now pushing you it's not
that I'm pushing him and he said he's
switching me I go wait I'm not ready
okay as opposed to this thing's moving
me you see that thing's weird
another Telltale sign is he goes in that
hand do you see where that hand did
that's that's clearly like whoa okay or
he goes and you're like trying to get
your elbow on the mat and you see how I
Crunch and I lower myself okay so
instead he's pushing me
um and I am going to go just wherever he
takes me oh
oh
he'll do it
there's no hand reaching there's no
trying to lower himself he just lets the
energy go in
Energy's going
he doesn't
try to absorb some there he just
connects his Center to the hand and it
displaces
he goes okay uh so watch for those
little signs of elbow lowering myself
hand actually Reaching Forward okay
let's try it again but this time the
Naga is the one pushing that you can't
try it
so to to finish this point
going back to that alchemical or that
yogic I understand in the body as he
organizes his body so this again for
simplicity's sake so this Hada does not
disorganize he is actually
um
ritually yogically alchemically uh
reconciling fear from his person okay as
opposed to if he was here all day
flinching out of fear you see and you're
going to see that uh he would have
adrenaline dumps and he would feel sick
after a while
but now it is training alchemically he
by keeping his Center organized he's
actually developing himself
into that Fearless reconciled state
well he's also training on his Center
organization so he's not wasting time a
zoo kid okay
okay
go back to the first thing
let's do mine first okay
okay first of all remember that yin and
yang is relative
so that means from
you can't make static lists you often
see static lists but if you understand
the list statically you you suck that
your ego tripartite mind has you okay
Yin is Yin from a particular perspective
okay
and the same goes for young okay
so oftentimes you hear me say young
young Clash it is and it isn't okay what
it's not though is it's not
non-contestation that's the problem okay
in other words if he's running at me
with his face and I can punch his my
fist through the back of his head
his head was yet
do you understand that okay
even though it's coming this way it was
yin to my fist all right
that said
you can you can you of course can do two
young moves do you see
Yukon of course do two Yin moves
and still do cookie Dosa all right
there's a reason why Aikido does not do
that and I'm a I am a belief but you'll
see me do that every once in a while but
I'm a firm believer of
don't have your internal drills be so
far removed from your Tactical
architectures
um
don't do that because you'll have a
bigger stepping stone when you try to
put them into practice okay the internal
drills are exaggerations and extending
of the internal aspect moment for the
reason of cultivating it but in fighting
it's never going to be that long neither
in in how much it travels through space
or how long a duration okay
um so already you're looking at that's
pretty far enough away from my tactical
architectures okay and if I start doing
things like for example I do two yins
that kind of works in terms of uh uh
an internal projection but go back but
I'm going to get head butt boom on the
way in it's not going to work okay
so what your Ico does in ITS Tactical
architecture is one hand is going to go
in
and the other hand goes yum
one hand goes again the other hand goes
young you have to watch when you're both
gone or you're both young
some of you are going both in not
realizing it and you're all jacked up
okay it's hard making it harder for you
there's another reason why Aikido does
one year when young even though you you
don't have to so well you don't have to
you see you don't have to but there's a
reason why I key to the desert and it's
because of that Prime that perennial
philosophy you always work both sides of
the yin yang
and you always integrate them and you
always reconcile them and you always
transcend them okay and that is again
another reason aside from the Tactical
architectural reason that you don't want
to have two yins or two Yarns okay work
the two together
so I'm going to standardize them right
now
okay we're gonna go to the right
so this will be my
Yin hand over the top this is my young
hand
I'll aim in his Center
I want you to try it with your hand on
the inside
try it with your hand on the outside and
low
the yin hand will stay the same the
young hand changes
on the inside
blowing the outside
in hand stays the same
so again
inside always into The Descent
get done outside
just be careful not to go over the top
of him
goes into his Center
into the center
in the center
oh
into this okay
okay let's try
okay going again there's it's a
concentric art so there's multiple
levels they're all doing the same thing
at a different level okay
okay so uh as I go I don't want this
watch watch The Hidden Hand the yin hand
is going to yield you see same
and even though this hand is like this
if this head comes back here that's too
Yin hints do you see how how do you know
can you head don't head with me what can
you head butt me do you see it's too Yin
hands okay so you have to watch why did
I do two unit hands because eventually I
want to do two young hands
you see and then you'll see my hands
came together
okay
alchemically I want to open my body open
my body
so if he moves out of the way let go you
see I'm here like this my hands are
moving apart
so I want you to watch that as I do the
technique
not two hands
that's two young hands you see
this side is going this way
this has gone that way
oh
this way
I do the other they get on one same
thing
not going to be too young hands
see our hands are moving away from my
torso
moving away this way
not both that way okay let me try it
again okay
open open
open open spread your hands apart okay
let's go